leaders could just take this um advice
observe people don't get lost in
uh trying to impress or steer the ship
all the time or trying to
provide face time observe your people
because if you can observe their body
language and how they're interacting
you're going to learn a lot more from
them than you would in just a regular
conversation
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet
latonya wilkins
founder of change coaches and author of
leading below the surface latonya
partners with executives upwardly mobile
professionals and teams to build
cultures of belonging through highly
customized coaching and learning
experiences she is a sought-after
keynote speaker and has inspired
audiences around the world she built her
career working in hr talent management
and learning and development at fortune
500 companies before teaching and taking
on progressive leadership roles at the
university of illinois ghias college of
business latonya's book leading below
the surface how to build real and
psychologically safe relationships with
people who are different from you was an
amazon bestselling new release in
multiple categories all of our work is
based on below the surface leadership
principles
well latonya this show is all about
leadership and all about different
experiences of leadership and different
principles and perspectives and stories
and i'm really really excited to have
you here as an author as a coach as an
executive and i'm excited to hear about
your personal journey and and the way
that you're perceiving leadership and in
all its shapes and forms so thank you
very much for being here
absolutely i'm happy to be here i love
talking about all things leadership
amazing well you know take me back a
little bit into
into what your you know the way you're
experiencing leadership today if you had
to think through
leadership and and and distill it down
to a few key characteristics that are
specifically profound to you
what would those be
yeah so mine is all about
what i call leading below the surface
and
it's about uh
you know building real connections with
people who are different from you so
what does that include well it includes
uh being a good listener uh being
empathetic
being able to observe people
it means what i call real leadership
which is an archetype
being relatable equitable aware and
loyal
it's also around
building psychologically safe
relationships
with people um when i went back and i
thought about all the best leaders that
i've ever had those were really the
qualities that they had it wasn't oh
they were innovative or strategic it was
those things and sometimes we kind of
get lost and like
those magic words of oh they have to be
innovative or strategic or all these
these fun words but it really comes down
to how you treat people
and and when you're looking at the way
the way leaders treat people and what
distills it then somebody to being a
good leader how where in your career in
your life have you observed this quality
of kindness empathy listening to be a
really important part of being a good
leader
yeah so i was uh working at a consulting
firm at one point in my career
and
what happened is i was able to
win us a big client a big client
extension
and so
uh
they this consulting firm decided to
have a big party to celebrate uh that i
that we had won this deal and uh the
party just wasn't my thing it wasn't the
way that the party was set up um the the
people at the party
um you know i probably would have rather
done something else like
um you know a little bit more intimate
uh and so i went to that party uh even
though i because i wanted to feel
grateful and i wanted to show the
company i was grateful and one of the
leaders who actually threw the party uh
came up to me afterwards uh during our
one-on-one and he said
hey you didn't look like he had a lot of
fun at that and i was like uh you know
it was okay you know and he was like no
it wasn't okay you did not have fun you
did not look happy you know what was
going on and
we were able to have a conversation and
it was like the first time in my career
that that had ever happened i wasn't
being punished it was a very
psychologically safe conversation um and
we were able to talk about you know how
to celebrate uh me in the future and if
leaders could just one of the things he
did and leaders could just take this um
advice
observe people don't get lost in
uh trying to impress or steer the ship
all the time or trying to
provide face time observe your people
because if you can observe their body
language and how they're interacting
you're going to learn a lot more from
them than you would in just a regular
conversation
incredible and how do we do that at
scale do you think so if we're running
organizations at the end the way you are
experiencing as leaders sometimes is
we're talking to a crowd sometimes we're
talking and we're not
there to see the immediate reaction yet
we still want to embody those same
principles of observability kindness and
empathy that you're talking about so
what do we do at those moments
yeah you know i think when you're
talking to a crowd it's uh
you know i do a lot of keynote speaking
and so it's
whenever i keynote i always think this
is not about me talking to people it's
about me uh this is for the audience
it's about me connecting with the
audience and that's the number one thing
that i do
and um with that you at scale you you
listen to the like as you're talking you
look around you see how people are
receiving things you call people in
and you see and you're constantly
adjusting to this you know the thing is
michael is like it doesn't have to be
hard for for traditional leaders that
are in leading organizations because you
know you could do this type of stuff in
one-on-ones you could do this type of
stuff in team meetings
one of the ways you could do it in team
meetings is instead of again trying to
steer the ship with an agenda you take a
step back and observe how your team is
interacting and you can learn a ton
about them by doing that
incredible hey latanya walk me through a
little bit about your own journey i'm
i'm really curious to hear how one gets
to be occupied with this question of
leadership and coaching uh such a
meaningful part of your life what what
what led you there
yeah so i
actually it's funny because my career
started as a traditional corporate
career i led
global leadership development teams and
talent teams
and uh i just wasn't uh i i realized it
wasn't my calling was i content yeah but
there was more calling me and what was
calling me
is something that i learned from my
grandma and that was the importance of
building relationships with people who
are different from you building real
relationships with people who are
different from you and this kept um this
calling kept getting louder and louder
as time went by uh 2020 it started
it got a little increasingly louder and
then it just kept increasingly going up
and um
that's when i
uh kind of left corporate i i went to to
work for a business school
and lead culture and leadership there
and uh from there
um i was able to also
kind of be in stealth mode a little bit
and figure out hey what do i want to do
with all this
uh you know i what do i want to do with
this calling and so that's when i
did some coach training my mentor was
urging it she's like hey just do some
coach training i was like i don't know
i'm already a coach she's like no you
really have to do this so i did it and i
loved it and um that's what i was like
hey
my mission is to change the way we lead
and the way we lead we have to think
about you know how we treat people
especially people who are different from
us and that's the that's the missing
secret sauce here that we're not talking
about when we talk about diversity and
inclusion it's really about you know
creating belonging for for everyone and
so um that's that's it's been my calling
as you can see it's a it's a passion of
mine it really started with my
grandmother kind of modeling that
behavior and i knew that the world
needed this
i love it tell me a little bit about
learning how to coach
and you know from the from your
experience you know you're talking about
how helping people become better leaders
what do you have to go through as a
leader yourself to
to be able to coach people to do that
yeah so
that's a really good question
it's funny because there's a lot of
people out there that call themselves
coaches and they
they and i when i experienced them i'm
like wow this is this is more like
advising um you know to be a coach uh
the first thing
um you have to be
comfortable with silence
uh
in reflection and that takes a long that
took me a long time where do you meet
silence and reflection as a coach um
so when i'm coaching especially when i'm
coaching teams people need
they need room to reflect um most of the
change happens outside of the coaching
sessions so when i'm asking people a
question for example a powerful question
for them to reflect on um you know how
they might have handled a situation or
how they want to handle a situation um i
think the uh american thing sometimes is
you gotta answer fast you gotta answer
what's in your head but no that actually
is not a way to reflect so you have to
be
comfortable with
different ways people interact and a lot
of people might need you know some time
to chew on that or they might need to
come back to it later in the session or
they might even need to come back to it
down the road um you know after a week
or so after they've had time to think
about it um silence is so important i'm
glad we're talking about this and so
important science is so important
because um a lot of us again we're
really uncomfortable with it but that's
again that's where a lot of that magic
happens that's where a lot of the a-ha's
occur is when you as a coach can see
that silence and you can call it out
and you can call it out in a way that's
psychologically safe and non-judgmental
and be able to use that as a medium to
connect better with the client
incredible incredible okay so silent
being okay with silence observability
what what are other things that you've
learned as yeah as a coach the second
thing and i i actually said this out in
my newsletter yesterday
you have to be willing to throw out your
agenda
and a lot of people are afraid to do
that and why i get it um we are afraid
to do that because i i think when we
feel like we have control of a session
or control of the agenda we feel more in
control and that gives us a sense of
confidence but what if i told you
that it the best coaching sessions are
the ones where there's no agenda the
client comes up with the agenda and that
when your agenda goes out the window
because and a story i have is
some clients that one client i was
recently coaching and this happens quite
a bit
we had an agenda all set up uh she
wanted some coaching because she was
getting ready to meet with her board
and with ceo
and um
i could tell something was off
and i could tell there was some
something traumatic going on that was
taking over the session and so we threw
out the agenda we didn't talk about the
board um we we explored what was really
going on and what was really going on is
just an overall sense of confidence
about the whole thing that we were
talking about um about the whole um
thing that she wanted to present to the
board and so it's uh you have to be okay
with that um as coaches we call that
dancing in the moment
and in the moment it's it's wherever
that that coaching session takes you
wow okay so that and that goes back to
that
observability piece and leadership that
you were talking about before that ties
in the empathy and kindness and
understanding who you're talking to and
how they may be perceiving what you're
doing right
yeah yeah
so if go ahead
yeah and the third thing the last thing
i will say um and even though there's
more this is not an exhaustive list by
any means is you got to be okay
saying you know that's outside of my
expertise
a lot of times um we bring people in or
we we as coaches we we want to be right
we want to be the savior um but you will
actually gain more respect if you say if
if there's something going on and you're
not the best person to talk about that
with um you know i i had a client
um that um i was coaching and they
needed additional resources
they needed additional resources on
financial finances and funding and
things like that and so um i was able to
say hey i'm this is this is where our
relationship starts and stops um do you
agree with that um okay so let's figure
out how you get the extra help that you
need
okay got it so if you're if we're
looking now leadership is more
generally and we're looking at
individuals as any and every individual
is a leader in their own domain what are
the main challenges that you see
leaders facing in their day-to-day where
what are some patterns that are
constantly coming
again and again
and you know the average individual that
is trying to be a leader in their own
life
yeah you know i love that question
michael because i think it's it's that
the the future of leadership and the
future of work it's um what we're we're
all kind of grappling with right now
like every month seems to pose something
different um you know the pandemic and
the ups and downs of the pandemics and
the
and you know the unevenness of the
pandemic where in some areas it was
worse than others
hybrid work remote work um you know
diversity and inclusion how do we
actually do this for real how do we
actually change our culture um in the
dna of our culture uh for diversity and
inclusion and now also wars right now we
have any day of the week a war could be
started um and our employees uh will be
uh you know traumatized by that and so
as leaders we we have to adjust to a lot
and so there's no checklist anymore it's
it's again it's all about the core of of
how we work as a leader in order to be
able to address a lot of these issues
incredible latonya i really want to
thank you i know how incredibly busy you
are and you have to and now now work on
do
give a workshop this morning but i do
appreciate you taking the time to
to join me here and share a little bit
about your perspective on leadership and
and i definitely going to continue
thinking about we were talking about the
empathy observability our ability to not
always be at the forefront and sharing
this is how good we are but being able
to reflect and and and say okay how can
we be how can we give to the others and
and and i i loved how you mentioned that
this the leaders that sustained in your
memory until today and that made the
biggest impact are not the ones that
were the smartest the most intelligent
the most successful ones they were the
ones that listened to you they were the
ones that that made you feel important
made you feel hurt and i appreciate that
and thank you very very much
yeah thank you so much thanks for having
me this was fun
[Music]